sovereign debt is eating the world how
can you protect the assets you love we
are in a funny spot in terms of the
global economy at the moment in short
governments and central banks deluded
themselves into thinking that unlimited
deficit spending financed by unlimited
money printing will not do what it has
done for literally Millennia crash the
economy they are sadly wrong and we are
seeing the catastrophe unfold before our
eyes the story really begins in the
1970s when Richard Nixon broke the gold
standard but the latest chapter starts
in 2008 when central banks bailed out
the financial system by effectively
printing trillions of dollars thing is
everybody knew for centuries really that
so much money printing would cause
inflation perhaps with a 12 to 18mon
delay but it didn't in 2008 why because
the the banks held on to the free
trillions they used it to plug trillion
doll sized holes in their balance sheets
combined with an ongoing freebie as
China's manufacturing Miracle lowered
the cost of consumer goods meanwhile a
second salutory myth was shattered by
Japan again everybody had known since
forever well since the century that
public debt Beyond a certain level was
problematic that was generally
understood to be about 100 to 12 5% of
GDP but Japan crossed that line in 1998
25 years ago and nothing happen now
there are idiosyncratic reasons for
Japan largely the proportion of debt
that is domestically held and to be fair
Japan's economy has not been doing that
well over the period but the lesson was
learned debt is not catastrophic meaning
if debt doesn't matter deficits don't
matter now in both cases these
conclusions are contrary to literally
Millennia of economic history in fact
printing money does lead to inflation
and in fact when debt gets big enough
governments do tend to default in fact
we've had 14 Sovereign defaults since
1998 since Japan crossed that 100% line
still 2008 in Japan gave governments and
central banks around the world
confidence that maybe this time is
different unfortunately this dangerous
confidence was implemented worldwide
with coid to bribe voters into lockdowns
countries around the world spent money
as fast as humanly possible Central
Bankers then financed those deficits as
fast as humanly possible it all came to
roughly $ trillion in new money in just
a few years in the US by 2021 roughly $1
in3 had fresh ink on it so alas this
time was not different inflation did
take off as I mentioned before coid
globalization was holding back inflation
the printed money didn't show up in
prices but coid lockdowns overwhelmed it
that matters because it takes take
central banks out of the game central
banks cannot Finance government deficits
if they are simultaneously trying to
reduce the money supply so paired with
debt to GDP ratios over 100% in
basically the entire world this is now
causing investors to worry if
governments including major governments
will default that can that fear can pull
investors out of government bonds
leaving more for the central Bankers to
pick up which they aren't because
they're trying to fight inflation we've
got an ugly little twist here which is
that the main way central banks fight
inflation is by choking off the private
economy with interest rate hikes it's
exactly what they've done these past two
years hiking rates a total of 276 times
worldwide these are now crashing most of
the world economy into recession
including Europe the US and China
recession historically makes deficits
and debt even worse so we have the three
Horsemen inflation sovereign debt crisis
and looming recession we can illustrate
The Perfect Storm of the 2009 European
debt crisis that started when there was
a loss of confidence in Greece by
investors which was flirting with the
fault investor fear then spread to
Portugal Ireland Spain and Cyprus all
were ultimately bailed out by the ECB
the European Central Bank promising to
buy unlimited government bonds
essentially the debt was converted into
money the problem is that with inflation
today at 6 or 7% Rising central banks
can't do that they can't convert debt to
money because they're afraid that
they'll lose their independence that
they can't get a handle on inflation so
the standard recent solution to a debt
crisis is out of the game because of
inflation so what does all this mean for
investors well first up we have the
dollar there a weird paranox where
nobody wants the dollar but its price is
holding up just fine currency Guru step
Jen put out a chart earlier this year
showing that the US dollar Reserve share
went from 73% worldwide in 2001 to 50 5
by 2021 so relatively leisurely decline
but that had absolutely plunged by eight
points in the wake of the uh Russia
invasion of Ukraine that was because the
US seized the dollars owned by Russia's
Central Bank they did this to try to set
off a bank run but ironically enough the
US got Bank runs instead but it put
every country on Earth on warning that
US dollars are a very dangerous thing to
hold so a lot of those countries shifted
out of dollars into either currencies
like the Yen Euro or into hard assets
like gold so nobody wants the dollar and
yet it's holding its value just fine
since 2001 it's been steady and in fact
it's risen over the past year even as
the reserve share plunged why because
the road to Dollar death is paved with
the corpses of other weaker currencies
essentially as World falls apart Safe
Haven demand goes to the dollar this
happened in 2008 even though the crisis
was literally coming from the US this is
related to Santiago capital's dollar
milkshake model model it means that the
US could be the least dirty shirt over
the coming decade essentially getting
stronger with each currency death all
the way into the final Ragnarok having
said an interesting threat to the dollar
that's getting attention these days is a
prospective replacement from some kind
of gold backed bricks currency now it's
important to note that would not be a
national currency so like they wouldn't
be backing the ruble or the Chinese Yuan
with gold because all countries want a
weak currency so their exports are cheap
now the idea would be that China or
Russia would float an external gold rail
that would replace the external dollar
that they currently use for trade so
just as the dollar is outside right
Chinese don't use the dollar day-to-day
back home they only use it for trade
they would similarly use some kind of
goldback Bricks now if this happened it
would be a very big deal because it
would be genuinely Superior to a dollar
assuming of course the market trusts
China or Russia to redeem to redeem the
gold which is a big wh if and that's
kind of the flying the ointment none of
the bricks countries are particularly
trustworthy plus the big ones are very
distracted at the moment so Russia has
its War China's economy is going through
hard times so I don't expect much from
brics in the near term but it is worth
watching because it would set up a
genuinely Superior competitor to the
dollar all right so all of that is what
could happen but what are the odds so
first off we may know how the book ends
but we don't know how each chapter ends
many times the financial system is
seemed on the brink and we somehow
through because remember the economy is
made of hundreds of millions of people
who are trying their best to dodge the
falling Boulders so could take months
could take years could take decades
having said I think we can say how the
book ends because the factors driving us
to collapse don't have guardrails to
illustrate how could we stop a crisis so
there are two ways fiscal and monetary
fiscal meaning dramatically reduce
government spending perhaps even pay off
the debt and monetary meaning reduce the
ability of central banks to finance
those deficits via inflation what would
take on fiscal is either voters waking
up and realizing in mass that we are
headed for the cliff or some balanced
budget mechanism Constitutional
Amendment or perhaps Warren Buffett's
plan that if Congress can't balance the
budget they all have to resign with a
lifetime ban from politics they would
probably find a way failing that default
also balances the budget because nobody
will lend to you after you default of
course in the US case that would
evaporate 34 trillion in paper wealth
which would wipe out thousands of banks
companies Pension funds it would get
ugly and then the other way to stop the
fiscal collapse is monetary here you
could either End the Fed in fact and all
central banks that would force
governments to actually Finance their
deficits in the private Market which
would not have the appetite for 10
trillion at a time of course governments
know that their licensed counterfitters
their central banks are their mother's
milk so that won't happen bringing us to
the most likely solution drain the FED
meaning people shift into gold or
Bitcoin or other non-fat currencies
which takes the livestock off the table
their dollars can no longer be diluted
siphoned to finance government spending
but of course this is a frustratingly
slow process before getting into the
punch lines to all this I want to
mention briefly commercial real estate
which is a huge asset class and could be
a trigger for crisis the sector is
massively overbuilt after 15 years of
near zero interest rates and now that
rates are soaring it is unwinding this
causing problems in Europe Canary Warf
Sweden's apartment Developers but it's
really becoming a crisis in American
cities because that unwind is running
into two combing factors postco work
from home and the abysmal Urban
governance in places like San Francisco
and New York is driving companies out of
large American cities leading to write
Downs of 60% or more in cities like San
Francisco now commercial real estate as
a concept isn't dead So eventually
prices fall enough that we see Bargains
but I think near term you'd want a limit
exposure until we see how especially the
US plays out voters are not getting as
angry as fast as you'd expect in places
like San Francisco perhaps thanks to a
gaslighting media so those cities may
continue collapsing for some time so
what are the implications of all of this
for investors in short if Sovereign
defaults are coming it would take Banks
insurers and pensions down with it you'd
want to insulate yourself both as an
investor and as a business executive
meanwhile I think it's likely that we're
in for years of high inflation meaning
5% plus which could boost nominal yields
but could actually reduce post inflation
yields below zero to illustrate right
now money markets are paying 5% but
inflation in the US is close to 4% so
that's not that great of a deal it's a
little over one above all higher
inflation suggests hard Assets in the
inflationary 1970s equities and
residential real estate held up just
fine gold went up 20 fold from 35 an
ounce to nearly 700 so what is different
this time is Bitcoin which is an
interesting asset class it's basically
what would happen if gold had a baby
with a doom so it's deep deep value
paired with deep growth after all
Bitcoin is essentially gold that
governments can't seize but it spreads a
lot like people realizing the Internet
is real in the 1990s remember Paul
krugman's fax machine so I think Bitcoin
could go up enormously if we're in for
inflationary crisis but of course
subject to the fact that Bitcoin has
idiosyncratic drivers that influence how
wide it spreads so regulation
institutional access number go up
finally implications for humans is looks
dire but remember we have been through a
lot worse it is true that some
inflationary collapses can last
centuries so Rome or Song Dynasty China
but when the hard times come men do get
strong voters concentrate their minds
post Civil War America looked like it
was done for example half the country
was flattened by General Sherman the
rest of the country was going through
hyperinflation courtesy of Mr Lincoln's
greenbacks yet the crisis concentrated
voters mind ushering in the re
establishment of the gold standard in
1879 which then led to about a 35e
period of the most epic golden age in US
history really in the entire world
essentially the entire modern world was
invented in a 35e stretch the us became
the most properous prosperous country
the world had ever seen so don't lose
hope on the other side is a radically
smaller government radically expanded
space for Innovation bottomup community
and Liberty in short a storm is coming
but it is likely to be beautiful on the
other side